bonsoir claude avant d'être avec nous
alors l'ouverture d'une ambassade
d'israël aux états aux émirats arabes
unis
pourquoi est-ce un événement important
c'est important parce que ça traduit et
comme vous venez de lire la corde
abraham qui a été conclu il y a quatre
mois à washington entre israël les
émirats arabes unis et entre israël et
le bahreïn et avait accompagné d'un
accord dans une déclaration trilatérale
que le président trump lui-même assigné
pour garantir naturellement le la bonne
entente
donc je crois que c'est important ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'un pays
arabe normaliser ses relations avec
israël puisque l'egypte l'a fait des 79
après les accords de camp david et que
le royaume de jordanie l'a fait en 94
mais évidemment la nouvelle rafale de
pays arabes qui ont renoué avec israël
ou qui s'apprêtent à le faire et du il
faut le reconnaître à la diplomatie de
donald trump et de son gendre et
conseillers jared kushner alors tu
important parce que ça va permettre de
développer des rapports économiques
ça va permettre de développer les
échanges de personnes le tourisme
puisque les visas seront supprimés entre
les deux pays qui viennent nourrir des
ambassades
hier par conséquent je crois que c'est
une marque importante de progrès de
reconnaissance entre des pays qui sont
voisins et qui ne veulent plus se faire
la guerre alors émirats arabes unis donc
mais aussi à bahreïn sont dans maroc
pourquoi ces pays club blanchemaison
normalise t-il leurs relations avec l
état hébreu
alors comme nous vont le lire c'est
évidemment sous la pression américaine
qui le font mais je crois que ça
correspond aussi à la perception qu'ils
ont de leurs intérêts et à une forme de
prise de conscience de l'importance
économique et de l'importance également
stratégique d'israël l'importance
économique on la voit dans les accords
qui ont été conclus entre les émirats
arabes unis et israël dans le domaine du
tourisme mais aussi dans le domaine des
hautes technologies et dans le domaine
agroalimentaire la plupart de ces pays
ont besoin des technologies que
qu'israël pressel et ont besoin aussi de
pouvoir apporter des produits
agroalimentaires plutôt que de les faire
venir deux contrées beaucoup plus
lointaine donc l'iard en effet des
complémentarités économiques et puis il
ya aussi le fait que ces pays se méfie
de l'expansionnisme site iranien et que
cela leur permet aussi d'utiliser israël
comme com com et éléments de pour
contenir cet expansionnisme sites
iraniens
en plus certains au passage peuvent y
trouver un avantage un avantage
particulier lorsque le maroc a négocié
dans les mêmes conditions sous la
pression américaine
la normalisation de ses rapports avec
israël
eh bien il a demandé aux états unis de
faire une déclaration dans laquelle les
états unis disent le sahara occidental
fait partie du maroc ce qui peut être
considéré comme normal mais que ce qui
n'est pas exactement la position
internationale aux nations-unies et
c'est un cadeau fait au maroc qui
d'ailleurs a fait peu a suggéré à
protester à a conduit aux protestations
de l'algérie et bien sûr aux
protestations aussi des militants du
sahara occidental
donc à chaque fois il ya une
contrepartie que les états qui signe
avec israël s'efforce d'obtenir de la
part les états unis je crois que en
effet il y en aura probablement d'autres
on parle du sultanat de oman et puis le
gros morceau qui viendra peut être un
jour c'est celui de l'arabie saoudite
on croit savoir que
le prince héritier mb s est favorable à
cette normalisation mais qu'il a
quelques difficultés avec des membres de
la famille royale qui sont à notre avis
et surtout par des chefs religieux qui
considère que ce n'est pas le moment de
le faire donc bien les choses
progressent chemine et on verra comment
l'administration de biden gère cette
affaire alors la normalisation de ses
relations cela nous rapproche qui nous
cela nous est loin dit il au contraire
d'une résolution du conflit israélo
palestinien
évidemment cela suscite les
protestations des palestiniens de
l'autorité palestinienne et des
mouvements palestiniens c'est logique
puisque eux considèrent que cela
renforce la main d'israël et que cela
retarde d'autant la reprise du dialogue
avec israël et par conséquent la reprise
des négociations
et cela même provoque chez les
palestiniens
le refus de tout contact pour le moment
avec l'émissaire américain ou avec des
émissaires des pays qui reconnaissent
israël
cela dit encore une fois c'est le
réalisme qui triomphait et l'état
d'israël existe il a une certaine un
certain poids économique il a un certain
poids également géostratégique et par
conséquent il faut sans s'en remettre à
la la réalité des choses et après tout
le fait que des états reconnaissent
qu'israël retire un motif de guerre
entre danse dans ces pays et
probablement qu'à plus long terme cela
peut faire progresser vers la paix merci
claude hommes blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales